la guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
serait-elle en train de rattraper un
directement l'Espagne c'est clairement
la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui à
Madrid suite donc à cette série de
courriers piégés qui inquiète les
autorités espagnoles hier une explosion
une déflagration retentit dans
l'ambassade du crâne à Madrid un employé
à manipuler un courrier adressé à
l'ambassadeur du crâne lui-même la
lettre était piégée à l'aide d'un
mécanisme pyrotechnique l'employé a été
admis à l'hôpital avec de légères
blessures à la main un acte isolé
pensait-on à ce moment là sauf que la
nuit dernière deux autres courriers
suspects ont été interceptés et cette
fois détruit par les services de
déminage une première lettre est arrivée
au siège de l'entreprise d'armement
installasa à Saragosse une entreprise
qui fabrique notamment des
lance-grenades qui sont envoyées à
l'Ukraine par le gouvernement espagnol
un second courrier à lui était envoyé à
une base aérienne et une importante base
militaire près de Madrid et ce matin on
apprend par un communiqué des autorités
espagnoles qu'une quatrième lettre a été
adressée la semaine dernière au chef du
gouvernement lui-même le socialiste
Pedro Sanchez là aussi le courrier avait
été détecté et neutralisé par les
services de sécurité Pedro Sanchez qui
on le rappelle avait rompu avec la
tradition de neutralité et plutôt
passifiste de l'Espagne ces derniers
temps en décidant d'envoyer plusieurs
centaines de tonnes d'armement
militaires aux forces ukrainiennes peu
de temps après l'invasion russe
Julia gar